[Music]  my family is my priority and my work  fits in in and around that and I'm  fortunate to have a job where I can take  my family with me and I can Blake Lively  revealing to the insider what her trick  is to balancing mommyhood with work at  varieties power of women luncheon on  Friday I hope that my girls always feel  what a priority they are and say that  they can be professional strong powerful  women and they can also be mothers and  wives and daughters and he wants to  compromise one twenty nine-year-old mama  do stunned on the carpet in a teal  jumpsuit and said it's the women in her  life who have the most powerful  influence on her  these days my daughters but my mom  probably my and my sisters but really my  mom is the most powerful and  in my life and I'm amazing mother-in-law  - right there beautiful Tammy  [Music]  you